what's up man it's t-rex make sure y'all
check me out on the boulet kid podcast
man we doing it up don't worry about
nothing
who like have podcast special guests in
here my guy t-rell what'd it do man we
had so much fun uh doing uh your show
yes sir adam or a.d was in uh italy
cupcaking yeah he was doing
he was doing his thing
he thought he was special out there you
know he didn't look beautiful
yeah it was the whole thing he had to do
singing in the boat and [ __ ] i almost
cried yeah it was beautiful man
good times it's crazy because
you and i have never met until recently
but i feel like we've been
in i mean i've been doing radio since
2005.
yeah and we've had mutual friends um
and it's just never and we never ran
into each other yeah and i think it
might i don't know man i never really
had a relationship with tyga though
i think that i just never was like a big
tiger guy
despite like
see that's why we never ran into your
ass it wasn't even that he was always
hating that i was never hating he was
hating dude just say he was hating him
you have this you
you he was hating dog and just okay
was nasty no we i wasn't a big tiger
because everybody was a tiger fan like
he was hating i wasn't hating he was
just one of the radio dudes that was
doing it it's okay your mind has changed
now
no my mind hasn't changed you [ __ ] with
them
and he's uh probably the third greatest
club artist of all time damn
second future is one oh yeah number one
number two number two might be tiger man
number two
if we're talking about just songs you
could get off songs you can get off
right now and i'm talking like
i'm talking about like hip-hop [ __ ] i'm
not talking about edm [ __ ] i'm talking
about like
little john's probably number two
just all around just gonna make any
clubs
no a little john's number two man dennis
tiger now i'm somewhat hip-hop like like
you know what i'm saying like yeah
i'm pretty sure he'll take that tiger
skull
yeah i'm not a hater he went through a
whole run that that was beautiful i just
thought like last kings was just not
close i would wear as a white dude i
told you i'd look crazy rocking that
shirt
it's just it's the golden oil at pharaoh
in the beginning it was like real you
know technical you know everything was
detailed
it was some [ __ ] that i really would
actually put on but then we took the
brand to you know another level to where
we took it to tilly's and those the big
department stores we had to fill the
demand because once they felt like you
know and we had the first like cut and
so t-shirt ever to be in their store
everything else is like triple a
[ __ ] and people printing on it right
so we had a you know cut and so tv put a
design on it and it and it flew off the
roof
and then with those big stores when you
got about
2 000 stores and then you have to ship
to all of these stores right right and
they ordered order and that [ __ ] the
designs got to come out like this and i
had this young white dude he was white i
don't know why he didn't wear it his
name was ryan you know what i'm saying
and that [ __ ] knew how to design like
up crazy like t-shirts like seasons that
she was coming out and i was like damn
so i just let him do his thing i was
making money and at that point i just
was like oh well [ __ ] it did you [ __ ]
with all the designs yourself no i
didn't i didn't but that [ __ ] was making
money so i didn't even give a [ __ ] i
didn't even look into it like that so
once you entire split up like who owns
the last king's copyright
um
that's that's why that's that's that was
the difficult thing about it that's what
we got sued copyright you know i'm
saying and trademark infringement so at
that point was it death row that came at
y'all because you guys were banging that
death row last kings logo for a while
should should gave a blessing he did go
ahead you can have that you know what
i'm saying real quick you know what i'm
saying do the thing cool so we we rocked
it yeah but no just the pharaoh itself
though a lot of people wasn't it was
like [ __ ] i own it i own it i own it i
own it i own it so we could we try to
have a like a little distinct thing
about it which you know which made it
ours which had a l and a k for the nose
and the mouth and people wasn't feeling
that [ __ ] yeah and when i said we had
mutual friends i mean in 2010 11 12 i'm
in vegas at molly mall's house all the
[ __ ] time yeah uh
having some of the greatest nights of my
life and somehow
never ran into y'all there despite the
fact
we was going crazy out there too a
hundred percent before we get into molly
mo i'm just [ __ ] happy to be here you
know what i'm saying i got my glasses on
my [ __ ] brother had i'm like
he's [ __ ] you only do big rappers and
[ __ ] that's like huge or so i'm
like [ __ ] i'm huge right now that's how
i'm feeling yeah i'm saying but let's go
back in the money wall molly mall's
house tight strip hop days crazy you
remember strip hop no you don't remember
strip hop what the [ __ ] is that that was
the [ __ ] strip club that friends and
used to dj at oh that [ __ ] i didn't know
the name of it i just used to go
nip rapped about it on marathon i never
knew the name i wasn't even looking at
the name you know why because i was
always just like moving fast they had me
my i think of rock city bro i think of
rock city i think is strip hop
that [ __ ] was going crazy yeah i love
molly mall house man he gave us a lot of
swag man what is the craziest thing you
saw at molly moe's house um that [ __ ]
had two wolves over here yeah the two
timberwolves in the field to the left
when you walked in yeah i'm like them
real wolves you know for sure yeah and
since somebody tried to go over there
one of the girls we was with one day
tried to go over there and pet that
[ __ ] and that [ __ ]
almost went through the fence and that's
when i knew it was a wolf
i said god damn this [ __ ] look crazy
yeah the wolves the monkeys the cheetahs
and then just like but yeah just all the
animals just the whole like
african egyptian feel
uh you know
just muslim [ __ ]
like everything that happened it almost
yeah it was almost like a muslim
egyptian
muslim egyptian castle it was everything
wrapped into one and it was just it was
a beautiful thing man he actually would
i mean
we went there i mean we had last kings
already it was an idea you know what i'm
saying already
but just the way like the whole aura in
essence when i went to his home that's
when it really i really figured it out
it was like it clicked
this is it you i already knew about the
culture and i already knew where i
wanted to you know where i wanted to
bring it and how i wanted people to
respect it you know what i'm saying
because it was an acronym last is uh
leaders of art style and talent you know
i'm saying we was kings of that that's
where it originally um
came from um and i'm like damn when i
went to his house it was just like a
cold thing like you have you've been to
his bedroom paul yes the biggest bad
ever like his bedroom paul it's like 10
california kings but yeah he bring you
around this the first time a statue the
first time i went to his [ __ ] house
he brought me into his bedroom pause
and he takes me to his [ __ ] closet
and opens up a jewelry drawer and gives
me two eye style bracelets and he's like
that's you and i was like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] trying to pimp you i'm like what
the [ __ ] that [ __ ] spitting up him
bro no but he did bring us to the roost
he body was trying to pimp tiger i don't
know but i we went to the room and i'm
seeing these big ass statues yeah lupin
statues and i'm like what the [ __ ] i
based my whole ass king store off of
this man's
master bedroom yeah i based my whole
store off of that [ __ ] so if you ever
been there you remember that [ __ ] just
no [ __ ] that's how that [ __ ] bear room
look with a you know i'm saying my story
with a [ __ ] bed in it no it's crazy
because like i remember like uh
there was like just that era of like
maul being around y'all [ __ ] going on
the road with you guys yeah like it was
it was it was crazy like i i do feel
like um
you guys had so much to do with uh
you know just the west coast run that
everyone took the sound and yeah man
taught us a lot man maul taught us
[ __ ] how to really be a [ __ ] boss
[ __ ] and a king we pulled up to this
[ __ ] house
10 rolls royces [ __ ] made backs he
picking us up and made backs and [ __ ]
like and he let you drive it he show
chauffeuring us with security yeah giant
security remember that he had a seven
foot ass giant mountain [ __ ] bro
oh god he helped t raw get his first
rolls royce that's crazy because he was
first cause wasn't tiger living in vegas
for a second yeah we lived in vegas man
me my girl him no state tax and china
you know what i'm saying we all lived
there
what was it like like when uh cause like
you know we think of uh
oh and honey cocaine honey cocaine i
forgot about honey lived with us too wow
what happened to her big ass house i
don't know
she i mean she was like kind of like the
first lady of the the of the wave huh
yeah after she got she had fans yeah
after she got shot it kind of like i
didn't know she got shot yeah she got
shot we had this uh incident i don't
know if it was uh oklahoma or something
either oklahoma or nebraska the tiger
show either one of those yeah we was on
tour and we was on tour with yg around
that time too and it was a gang of blood
for some reason i don't know what the
[ __ ] happened they was banging on yg
this and that the other the case may be
when he performed he got off stage he
hollered at him boom boom boom boom
and i guess he you know he he he
if the situation died down a little bit
so
had to get on stage boom and them [ __ ]
was going crazy again started throwing
[ __ ]
you fell me out t-rod and then t-roll
through something back
[ __ ] y'all [ __ ]
and then they was like yo all right they
got kicked out the [ __ ] um so we
whatever you know it's normal for us
[ __ ] getting kicked out fighting
whatever the case may be because we was
on the lower run well yg is going oh
yeah so boom we we come out [ __ ] after
this show
they like nah we we everybody from the
squabble but all right
[ __ ] yg like oh no [ __ ] got a burner
i'm like all right [ __ ] it we gonna go
back on the bus so we like we gotta take
this street out here
and then we're gonna hit the highway
so honey cocaine you know she getting
bigger she thought she was the [ __ ] she
got her own [ __ ] now she got a sprinter
van and her ass didn't follow us her ass
made a left instead of her right and
they followed her ass [ __ ] and shot her
[ __ ] up
yup i don't know if she got shot in the
leg or she got one of them shits that
was crazy
yeah we got to stop the interview right
now uh listen man
i got to say about bluetooth our good
folks at bluechu uh one of our sponsors
for the podcast and a product that i use
all right now everyone thinks that you
know maybe
taking a product like blue chew which
has the same active ingredients as
cialis and viagra is a thing it's not a
thing it's very normal you might have
anxiety you might have stress you need
that confidence to get your [ __ ] on
alright trust me
you want to lay thor's hammer down on
that puss you know what i'm saying or
that butthole whatever you're into
let me tell you something best part
about blue chew
not only is it in a chewable form but
you know when we think about going to
the doctor's office and getting um a
prescription for something like this we
think about it as a maybe an
embarrassing conversation to have an
awkward conversation to have well
bluechu is an online prescription
service there's no visits to the
doctor's office that's right it ships
right to your door in a discreet package
and when i tell you blue chew helps you
if you're a man
achieve a harder and stronger erection
believe me when i say bud it's the
[ __ ] truth all right
it helps men combat all forms of ed all
right and let me tell you if you're
getting ready to go on a date
you just want to impress a young lady
you got to pop that blue chew man that'd
have your dick you it might add a half
an inch to your dick your dick's never
so hard in your [ __ ] life
i mean serious ain't being serious yo
even if you just want to jerk off and
just be like yo this is nice it's
[ __ ] amazing so go over to blue chew
it is a chewable tablet you don't gotta
swallow it no pills nothing like that
bluetooth licensed medical providers
they work with you they find the right
ingredient and the right strength for
your prescription it's so easy you go to
bluetooth.com consult with their
licensed medical providers and use the
promo code bootleg put it on the screen
bootleg at checkout all you got to do is
pay five dollar shipping and they're
gonna give you your first month of
bluetooth for free that's right you can
try bluechu for free go to bluechew.com
use the promo code bootleg and receive
your first month free
man oh man i am a user of the blue chew
and i [ __ ] with a shot shout out to
blue chew let's get back to the
interview did anyone get into tyga's ear
about starting to date blac chyna at the
time nah man that was his own choice
bennett you know what i'm saying because
because i feel like he kind of like
saved her if that makes sense because we
think of like in the this is before only
fans is before instagram blac chyna was
like a legend when we think of like
miami strip clubs like she was like one
of them names you would hear people rap
about and then
i mean but he
i would say it's the other way around
you know what i'm saying and i'll do be
joking the clown and clowning with her
or whatever the case may be so if you
ever see this like so
she made him
that's what i think because she was she
was that [ __ ] you know i'm saying that
[ __ ] she was that [ __ ] you had to go
request her to come out drake was
already then said her name and song she
was stripping she was doing her thing
[ __ ] was that k.o.d [ __ ] she was that
[ __ ] right you know i'm saying so and
rack city just came out you feel me we
just came out we was doing our thing it
was buzzing so boom he like he like man
i need to go get this [ __ ] so i felt
like you know it was only right to have
the top-notch stripper [ __ ] or you know
a [ __ ] doing her thing to elevate your
[ __ ] couples and to me you know so when
you're in a relationship it elevates you
right so and with them two being
together like true it was crazy you feel
me like she crazy shriver [ __ ] doing
the [ __ ] partying drugs doing all the
[ __ ] she turned that little [ __ ] out
she feel me
she turned that [ __ ] out on god in
heaven she put him on little kid
all kinds of wild [ __ ] one day look he
like man we gotta go getters we go to
miami [ __ ] we request her [ __ ] the
whole tour bus get off the bus
we go to the club we only going there to
request her she comes out [ __ ] he has a
stack of money in his hand i'm like this
is yo this is make a break we wasn't
even trying to enjoy the club we already
knew what was happening boom she came
out went up spoke to him he just handed
her the money we shook i'm like you got
the number you did all the she like got
a number
i'm like how much money
it probably was like
500 or something like that but it looked
crazy you know the ones look crazy you
know it's like whatever so he told her
all right cool got her number
called her right after he caught her
because he caught he's like come being a
rack city video
and then she flew down came to be in the
rack city video in vegas this was
in los angeles downtown wait but wasn't
there an original rack city video that
was shot in vegas and he shot it over
yeah that was like that was like the
world star video yeah then he had to
shoot it over because the [ __ ] was
booming you know what i'm saying the
record labels start getting behind it
put the budget behind it shot it over
brought her out and that was all she
wrote were you hanging
listen
there was a lot of speculation that tyga
was hanging and banging kylie before she
was 18 years old
how much were you around uh i was around
the whole time you was around the whole
time yeah i was around every every step
of the way homie was there any sort of
like hey man she's not 18 talk going on
like that's club business okay okay you
feel me that was cub business but after
cause of the day when people ask me that
yeah i'm like you gotta have parent
consent
i don't see mom and dad knocking on the
door
that song y'all you feel me i know
what's right from wrong but at the same
time that was his business and that's
what he decided to do
but if mom and dad is coming bamming on
the door and me as a parent i'm on your
ass yeah it's like kris jenner is
hanging out and mom and dad's not going
to the door what am i supposed to say
the mom's over here what i'm supposed to
do like oh no like man i'm just trying
to get in where i fit in anyway you know
what i'm saying pre-billionaire kylie
yeah pre-billionaire no nothing damn i'm
saying no nothing tiger walked through
that door so travis could close it
damn that's [ __ ] up i mean but people
moved on you know what i'm saying people
moving on people growing man i think
it's just dope to see like i think tyga
like i think what's dope to see just
you know
independently how he bounced back with
taste and
man
he's an entity in hip-hop um talk to me
about just like
what you've been doing over at no jumper
because i think um
you know there's always
if you have a great personality if
you're comfortable on camera like i feel
like nowadays there's like no reason for
you to not
start a platform or you know i feel like
what you and ad are doing and do know is
special man like when did you realize
there was something
there where you're like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] could actually really work
damn i when they when the first one the
first time they brought me you know i'm
saying i was in my store on melrose and
and i was chilling and you know i'm just
doing my thing quietly because i was in
the industry for a long time but i just
felt like you know the industry is full
of [ __ ] fake certainly dumb ass
[ __ ] yeah so i'm like man i
ain't got time to be bothered with that
i'ma just be over here
but call me he like man you want to do
this [ __ ] with a.d
[ __ ] show up you know what i'm saying
let me see what to see you to do but
that's my [ __ ] pun though i've been
knowing for a long time years 20 years
of course
so i'm like [ __ ] all right you know what
i'm saying let me see what to do here
like yeah we thinking about um replacing
this girl that's on here you know she
kind of i don't know she it's iffy i'm
like whatever i'm gonna get on there i'm
gonna turn up for y'all whatever i think
it's just gonna be one day
i got in there [ __ ] the lights cut on
like they cut on in here and i'm like oh
this is crazy they like all right go
record i'm like we live all right cool
and it's just easy i'm just talking i'm
like you know what i'm saying it was
some little [ __ ] named baby young and i
just start interviewing
yeah yeah so i'm like what's up [ __ ]
where are you from i'm like i don't even
know what's going on i wasn't trained to
do this this little mexican kid i'm just
going at it hey looking at me from the
side like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you got
going on i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] it you feel
me like but
i just knew from that day on like this
is it
this is i'm like i could do this all day
anyway it just ain't being recorded yeah
oh god and playing like come back next
wednesday six i'm like
oh it's lit
and i'm like cool i'ma [ __ ] with it i go
back again i'm like
this is easy money i could do this all
day this is what i'm supposed to be
doing talking [ __ ] yeah that's what i'm
supposed to be doing is it hard cause
even like uh i gotta like i've been on
three times two or three times on the
live show with some capacity over there
yeah and it's a lot different than
pre-recording
because you're live mm-hmm you're live
so like whatever you might [ __ ] around
and forget you're being like you're b
like it's live and everyone's watching
you in real time and let some [ __ ] fly
and be like [ __ ] that's the real
training though
did did something like that have to
happen for you to like really kind of be
like like did you let some [ __ ] fly that
you would kind of um yeah i did they
they kind of like pre-war me on
different things and this [ __ ] i should
say
like you know the lbtq community is a
little sensitive about little [ __ ] you
know because you know how we talk in the
ghetto and i'll be like man [ __ ] you
that's gay right and they like hold on
don't say
something gay
yeah and i'm like whatever and that's
just my whole little thing [ __ ] you gay
like right and then they like uh we live
they have to tell me like we had to tell
me i'm like oh my bad lptq i'm just you
know what i'm saying i don't even know
how to say this [ __ ] but i'm like oh my
god it's my bad
i'm gonna back my jeep yeah but yeah you
i mean this a couple times but not too
but not too crazy not too crazy is it
like um because i think a lot of people
see like you know adam's kind of put
together all these dope shows on on the
platform
um
and you guys all have your own
sponsorships like like i saw you posting
my bookie ad the other day yep yep yeah
um how is like just like the like are
you like i think a lot of people would
be like why wouldn't you and a.d go do
your own thing away from adam like what
is the obviously adam gave you guys the
platform
i mean for sure that'll be that'll one
day that that'll happen i'm pretty sure
he don't want us to stay under him
the whole time or all of our career
doing that [ __ ] like he's a cool dude
man he's super solid yeah a lot of
people be like you know putting that
[ __ ] on him like he he a [ __ ] or he
might be you know racist or [ __ ] him
people think he's racist huh people a
lot of people think he races he just
like he a [ __ ] and just like he [ __ ]
like and this and that in the other and
like it's just it's just different with
that [ __ ] like when i got to meet him
and i you know i like to go out and like
really [ __ ] with you and like and try to
see what your character is like i'm
trying to really judge you real quick
like i really be saying different [ __ ]
to you [ __ ] with you i might give you a
hug to see how you you know i'm saying
[ __ ] with it i just want to feel your
presence like and that [ __ ] he a cool
[ __ ] like so anything we we want
to do like however it is he going to
support us like 100 like he let me do
anything on his platform like i mean
[ __ ] i thought it was i mean now that
you're doing it you're doing interviews
on your own like i can do whatever i
want to do on this platform he like
whatever i can't have any i can make up
any [ __ ] little show or vlog
i can have my own podcast i can get away
from at the end of the day go start my
own [ __ ] go live on friday you feel me
and do that like he wants me to do that
and i'm like nah i'm gonna just build at
the end of the day with a.d because i
feel like we stronger me a d and dunno
together and then i'll you know i'm
saying i'll double back and make my own
[ __ ]
like that's what i'll do but
he was like well try to interview
because i was bringing him a lot of
people i felt like he should interview
and he like
why don't you do the interview yeah
matter of fact everybody do the
interview everybody in here let's see
what was the first interview you did it
was recently it was like the last thing
that
you're
doing
interview and i did it with uh um a.d
you know the little [ __ ] with the
report card that's what it was yeah it
was that [ __ ] and it just got he was
talking crazy about head hey oh yeah he
don't like dj head uh charisma he don't
like your ass either he don't like none
of you [ __ ] hey i'm glad he didn't say
my name i'm like whatever man my name's
bennett and i'm not in it well he didn't
say your name he didn't bring it up but
he don't he don't like none of y'all
[ __ ] he's
y'all ain't doing the right thing i just
think that you're using your platform in
the right way whatever
but yeah at the end of the day i [ __ ]
with adam you're a good dude no i always
tell people because i've known adam for
a while now and always be like yo he's
been nothing but solid and i think like
you know
some of the [ __ ] that he'd be getting
flack for is just white people humor
yeah like they had him on a clubhouse
with whack and they were bringing up all
these old ass like dark tweets he had i
i was like bro that [ __ ] was hilarious
like i if you watch like first of all
that was not hilarious you watched louie
ck stand up he says we're [ __ ] first of
all let's gently right there that [ __ ]
was not hilarious when he wrote look
when i i said what are we for he was
like let's get on the uh let's get all
wack [ __ ] we bout to talk about these
two it was just it was just some bad
humor some white people humorous [ __ ]
they sent me the tweets and i'm like
[ __ ]
what would make you say that
i'm like [ __ ] we can't be doing i'm
like i got one time to protect you doing
this [ __ ]
but he's not gonna let those things know
and nowadays i just know the type of
time you know and he ain't even on that
type of time he tried to be on some dark
human [ __ ] wasn't funny right
you found me that's just i know for sure
and i'm like that [ __ ] just wasn't funny
not for sure but for sure it's crazy
because like uh
you you've talked about this a lot but
just the whole [ __ ] max situation [ __ ]
max always on no jumper but yeah
you're a hoover he's got hoover killer
on his forehead do you get the email
that says
from this time to this time this guy
will be here
don't pull up
yeah they not gonna make it happen
they're not gonna do that that's crazy
like
i'm like this young [ __ ] first of all
he just young you know what i'm saying i
don't think he really got it all
and you know it just it ain't that time
yet but
i was like you know what i was telling
adam because he really [ __ ] with him
you know just as a person because when i
look at his interviews or when i look at
his vlogs and all that [ __ ] and i see
his how hospitable he can be like his
hospitality and going out there and
talking to people and having respect for
the elder folks and giving away to the
homeless and [ __ ] like he's a whole
different type of [ __ ] but when you
turn on that gang bang switch
it's like super disrespectful and it's
just like crazy but i can see why
adam might like him because that's the
um cmac that he know you know what i'm
saying even though he has ignorant
content and [ __ ] like that i was like
but he got that show on his forehead cuz
i can never
talk to that [ __ ] i could never [ __ ]
with him you can't be around or whatever
i'm like but he gonna see i'm like one
day he gonna understand and then one day
he adam
you're like should i interview i
interview with her
or you know or i do a skit with her and
i'm like i said i see [ __ ] no [ __ ] but
i see i was like see he growing you feel
me because all that clout and all this
[ __ ] like you want to keep that [ __ ]
going you know what i'm saying you want
to be successful for longer and you're
starting to feel like you got to reach
out to different people you got to start
[ __ ] with people even if they're your
enemies [ __ ] you feel me to get that
content out but
with that [ __ ] on your forehead that
[ __ ] gonna hold you back [ __ ]
you feel like there's like a fine line
though between like because when i saw
what happened with dude like when he got
dp'd and like
i mean
i feel like it sucks because like he's
kind of been made into this internet
personality
and the
and we forget that he's also a member of
a gang and like
there's consequences for maybe some of
the stuff that he feels like he has to
do for views or for the clout you just
mentioned
so i kind of almost feel like it's just
it's just a weird situation i'm sorry i
felt kind of it's not that i felt sorry
for them but i just felt like
damn like they're they're they're this
is how this was going to end up the
whole time based on one one i know they
they gonna it's gonna put a little extra
on it cause you here's who you is now
and two it's just it's game banging
that's what it is you gotta i mean
you're gonna get dp'd i mean and that's
just what the [ __ ] it is like [ __ ] and
they filmed it a little bit [ __ ] oh well
yo we gotta stop the interview real
quick shout out to our presenting
sponsor odd socks baby hey man listen
all i keep on my ass is odd socks draws
all i keep on my feet are socks you know
why because they're the most comfortable
socks in the world and i'm not just
saying this because they promote the
podcast i'm telling you the socks are
crazy uh they got all the licenses look
they got halloween socks they have back
to the future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks
old dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb all
right they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys these to
me are the most comfortable socks in the
world all right
so trust me when i say go to
oddssoxofficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
buying the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane
in [ __ ] sane uh go to
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev that's one word together
bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg cab is the promo code you
will get 20 percent off at checkout one
more time go to oddssocksofficial.com
save 20 off using that promo code
bootleg kev let's get back to the
interview yo early on um were you around
with during the ged days of the time
so this was like gata schoolboy q
yeah uh shout out to gada kate is um
doing his [ __ ] thing on dave yeah
shout out to gator too
it's crazy that like that was like a
pretty solid little entourage artist
when we think back like what was it like
being
uh and i just interviewed my homeboy uh
bubonic [ __ ] from philly most wanted
she's just from yo phil he's most wanted
yeah i just interviewed bubonic man
y'all go check that out man bruh
that philly's most wanted album was hard
as [ __ ] damn dawg
and i'm like [ __ ] this is bubonic and
this is like who
why i had to bring it back to you you
know i'm like dude i want to [ __ ] i
want to interview sean paul from the
young bloods bro damn
i feel like sean paul had like a little
underrated run where he was on every
random remix and it was hot and he was
just spazzing i don't know about the
other guy from the young bloods but no
yo philly's most one was crazy but what
was what were the early days like like
being around q back then like obviously
both of you guys are from the same you
know the same set early days with me and
cute me and q went back when before ged
me and q we used to work together we
used to live together in compton
like we from the 50s like like you go
before ged like one day at work he just
was like i rap
i'm like you rap i'm like oh you guys
working
we was working at some like [ __ ]
railroad company or some crazy [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying manual labor yeah
manual labor loading the trains and all
that me and him just you know
and he from like he from 51st street i'm
from 56th street and i didn't know this
[ __ ] until he got to work and i'm like
where you live or where you from and i'm
like [ __ ] i stay right there i'm like
for how many years he like and i'm like
[ __ ] never
i'm like never [ __ ] we even went to the
same high school like he graduated
christian i graduated crenshaw he's in
the ninth grade you know i'm saying i
was in the 12th grade but i'm like how
the [ __ ] did we not see each other all
the way till we got here i mean but
that's just how the universe work energy
work whatever was he always hilarious
my [ __ ] was always funny he was always
doing the same [ __ ] he might be the most
underrated like comedic personality in
all the music but that's how all my
homies is that's how i am that's how you
are i mean look and now it's working
yeah i mean if we get together it's
unstoppable it's the jokes is ridiculous
but it's it's a cool
10 of us like that's just crazy like you
can't [ __ ] with it at all why did the uh
ged thing not work out like with q and
tyga you know eventually obviously ended
up with tde um just because of the way
tiger do business exactly why i'm right
here you know i'm saying just the way
hot [ __ ] handle business and how
[ __ ] just be like out for self i mean
you can only do so much for [ __ ]
i mean you don't owe me [ __ ] but at the
end of the day it's kind of like
certain [ __ ] you supposed to do as a
friend you know what i'm saying and and
that's what it was with him like he knew
like his career wouldn't flourish with
ged he would he should he was he should
go over here to tde and this is where
it's at and that's where he decided to
stay hustle and grind you feel me and
then t raw he did his own thing over
here and you know he he flourished his
way it was hard as [ __ ] too don't get it
[ __ ] up even though he was signing
well he had to kind of force force cash
on his hand yeah you had he was on the
shelf
and he heated up with all the mixtapes
and it was like
yeah but it wasn't even
as far as you being on the shelf because
it was just it wasn't even that but like
he was never like like i feel like you
guys forced like universal's hand like
with that song yeah and coming out with
[ __ ] and doing mixtapes
done [ __ ] it was a different time back
then
and back then nobody was signed to young
money until lil wayne went to jail he
signed all the artists when he went to
jail right before he went to jail so he
can lock everybody in so yeah so they
didn't so around that time we really
wasn't even we've just said [ __ ] were
saying young money in cash money nobody
was signed wow nobody was signed until
that [ __ ] had to go to jail and when he
went to jail [ __ ] signed a deal and
then once they signed a deal then they
could start trying to figure it out you
feel me but even with the mixtapes
trying to figure it out that's why you
had the mixtapes trying to get a create
a little buzz and then being from young
money and universal like you get to do
like certain little shows to keep money
in your pocket and that's all i saw
that's that was the best we could do at
that time
with no nothing no hits no nothing but
shout out dj will though because he kept
shot it will man he kept that [ __ ] going
because if we didn't have that [ __ ] it
would have been bad what because ill
will hosted all those tapes right it
will host it all those tapes it will
host it all i just listed with it it
will it's my guy i love that guy man can
i interview you like no i'd like to be
behind the scenes behind the scenes i'm
gonna
[Music]
i have an adult softball game to go to
yeah yeah yeah he doing that yeah trust
me i tried to get him all i don't know
man kev you know i got some stories but
i think too like if will goes on like
will feels a lot of certain type of way
about a lot of artists
and i feel like he knows i know what
those like i i think he's
also very mindful that if he gets
interviewed he might burn some bridges
oh man he might piss a lot of people off
i mean but oh well [ __ ] the time is over
it's done [ __ ] [ __ ] burn the bridge
because he also didn't fan of a fan
right yep damn yep he did a fan of a fan
i mean cause chris didn't know either
chris i've been signed this whole time
his whole career and his life and he had
went through that that traffic moment
[ __ ] with him and rihanna and then they
was finna black ball his ass all the way
out which they already did they did they
did and shout out to my homeboy mijo
cause he hit me because that [ __ ] chris
was like it gotta be a way i could put
out music maybe i could put out music
like these [ __ ] right so who's the
best [ __ ] i should like collab with so
you know help me
and my boy mijo was like [ __ ] tiger
[ __ ] he doing it [ __ ] that's this is
all he do
they could call this [ __ ] we went down
to virginia [ __ ] we was down there for
like a month like two months [ __ ] we
live with chris
maybe we recorded [ __ ] video
because the incident happened in 09
so i'm assuming like 2011 2010 yeah like
2010
oh yep 2010. because deuces came out in
like 2011.
and that was a real single that was like
so yeah it was probably 2010 then so
2010 we went down there yep 2010. yup
hit us we went down there recorded all
of that [ __ ]
and then uh oh it was matter of fact
that was kevin mccall's song kevin
mccall wrote that [ __ ] from
ambers
very talented songwriter yeah he well
you know he was saving the song he was
like man
we was like let us get this song chris
kept [ __ ] get level get us this song he
kept playing songs and [ __ ] he was like
no i'm holding it for drake [ __ ] was
like [ __ ] you don't know drake
like
then you're not gonna never even see
drake that's what we talk about like
drake [ __ ] what the 2010 drake don't
know you don't [ __ ] with us like that or
he don't leave he ain't [ __ ] with you
so we like [ __ ] give us the song so he
finally gave christmas songs chris sung
that [ __ ] over boom t-roll
hopped on that [ __ ] and it was
all she wrote
[ __ ] we shot the video
shot the video of downtown [ __ ]
with colin shot the video with colin and
we tell it and you know tiger had the
relationship with colin because he was
the first one of the first [ __ ] that
was shooting with colin and doing [ __ ]
and kyle he was like colin look check
this out we only got like 2500. right
colin ain't doing [ __ ] from that right
now [ __ ] for probably half a million
couple hundred what's crazy if you think
about all like that era of west coast
videos was like black diamonds
remember black diamonds oh god they just
crazy they did like the early yg [ __ ]
the black diamonds used to go crazy yeah
they were stepping out though
yeah but colin did that [ __ ] for 2500 it
was over that's so crazy man
that's wild yeah was this like um was
this because i feel like um
in 2010 was chris like
heavy into the bloodshed
in 2010 was he heavy into the bloodshed
like not heavy heavy but you know he was
more so focused on trying to get his
career back trying to get back on the
right yeah and trying to get trying to
get some of that [ __ ] money back
yeah yeah cause he was on [ __ ] juicy
fruit commercials right he was trying to
he was trying to get it you feel me so
all that [ __ ] was like [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] but you know it was still there it
was still there for you you obviously
kind of were like brought that uh
credibility to tyga situation when you
see artists move to la
and you kind of start seeing them
affiliate they're not from here
but they start affiliating themselves
with certain neighborhoods or certain
games and [ __ ] it's dangerous yeah what
are your thoughts on that because i feel
like it happens a lot man and like i
i don't i don't i don't know you know i
see
i see this [ __ ] happen all the time i
say man rappers don't affiliate yourself
with nobody feel me just have your
tight-knit crew your people your family
your friends and then y'all just move
smart like don't affiliate yourself with
no game because gangs don't have no love
for you
you know like it was it was just cool
how i worked out with tiger because i
just felt i built a little camaraderie
with them and then you know i
i felt you guys were friends yeah i'm
just my little homie so i i treated it
as such but everybody not gonna get that
treatment you feel me like there's not
you can't name [ __ ] that's getting
that treatment right now like from no
neighborhood out here that's just gonna
back them a hundred percent because
these [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] about you
they'll rob you you feel me they'll kill
you like they'll do everything
above you feel me like so [ __ ] no don't
don't affiliate yourself with none of
that [ __ ] you feel me because that [ __ ]
is crazy because if i was that type of
[ __ ] like it wasn't it wouldn't be no
tiger right now yeah because if you
think about it like uh
how unnecessary it might seem if you're
like a kid from virginia
and you're like you've been famous since
you were a child
and like i think a soulja boy the same
[ __ ] right soldier was been famous since
he was a child yeah
even like bow wow sometimes you'd be
like he'll be trying to do a little you
know hardship but i'm like yo like
why is all that necessary you've been
famous that you were a kid bro like you
obviously didn't grow up like
coming from your neighborhood you had
like you know what i'm saying this is
your lifestyle i'll tell you why because
people be infatuated with the with the
just the culture and the feel of it you
know when i get around my homies like we
ain't always like oh god ho let's go
shoot and kill everybody like [ __ ]
ain't doing that [ __ ] if you from los
angeles california you [ __ ] know like
if you on the block [ __ ] and everybody
outside [ __ ] cooking [ __ ] is playing
in the street doing all the whole [ __ ]
shootings happen rarely right you know
what i'm saying like so if you out here
in this whole atmosphere [ __ ] we all
got on red you want to put on red too
it's like having that [ __ ] varsity
jacket thinking when you playing
football or basketball like i want a
jacket too
like you want to go out there and have
fun and do it up with your homies have
some culture have big homies and little
homies and all this [ __ ] it's just like
a family oriented thing
but it is another aspect of it where
maybe these other [ __ ] might come over
here because your homies and took their
[ __ ] party beat up they homies nah
they mad they don't want to fight now
they finna get their gun roll over here
shoot the wrong [ __ ] now
everybody hates you
you know what i'm saying now we gotta go
back over here and it's just gonna be a
never-ending [ __ ] story
that's the that's the worst part about
it but as far as like me kicking it with
all my homies like that's the craziest
party ever no i'm saying like ass pun
they got used to bring all my homies to
his party and we should turn that [ __ ]
upside down having fun right right right
but
if a [ __ ] want to fight and do all that
that's when they go left
but it's the family-oriented thing about
it i guarantee you and even soulja boy
these [ __ ] is from the south and when
they see that it's like oh this is cool
so do you think any of it has to do with
just like i live in l.a now it'd be a
good idea i mean and be affiliated with
some [ __ ] yeah partly too
but yeah it's yes and no because you
because back then i
for like artists getting like their
chains snatched like how do i get my
chain back like it happened that
happened to tiger right yeah um it
happened to a lot of people
being getting your change stats back
then was crazy like your career that was
like
yeah
it's pretty much was done i mean dude
that [ __ ] haunted
young berg for a while it pretty much
was for real [ __ ] like until i did get
this change snatch twice like when i
came around
like people was like really trying to
[ __ ] with them and bully them and do all
this [ __ ] because when you not from a
gang that's what gangs really do to you
too especially when you hot you popular
got songs out you on tv [ __ ] see you in
the street they want to take advantage
of you right and that [ __ ] just wasn't
flying with me so he already had the
coconut juice [ __ ] then [ __ ] was
already still trying to [ __ ] with them
and
and bullying and doing all that but when
i came around i'm like damn they doing
all of this [ __ ] to you i'm like all
right
get on youtube i'm like let me give me
the list of everybody that's that's
dissing you and [ __ ] with you right
now all right cool say no more i'll be
right back
like probably like a couple weeks [ __ ]
i spoke to everybody except one [ __ ]
you feel me i'm like hey that's out
[ __ ] we ain't doing that no more often
what was like it was like wrap beef that
you squashed just like little rabbits
and like little homies but it was a
couple [ __ ] that's really from gangs
you know i'm saying that was doing a
thing who's like the the most notable
beef you squashed for tyga in that era
probably the the young homie named
gutter he was for bounty hunters i mean
he was my homie too like he was my real
home like hey come to my house for me
i'm like hey i'm kicking it with the
young [ __ ] man lika along you know what
i'm saying we ain't gonna do that no
more because i ain't trying to [ __ ] up
my little reputation and all that my
homies call me a [ __ ]
feel me so we ain't gonna do that [ __ ]
no more for people who don't understand
um who aren't from la or don't
understand the politics of l.a why was
it such a
huge deal that you sat down with jay
stone and did get an interview with him
uh because those that's two big rival
gangs like
[ __ ]
some of my homies can't even look at
them [ __ ] or talk to them or even
stand by them or stand 50 feet away from
them without being hysteric like
crazy going erratic you know what i'm
saying like some of my [ __ ] can and
some of my [ __ ] can't like but
and vice versa like i can't go over
there you know what i'm saying like yeah
i could change my life i could do
whatever the [ __ ] i want to whatever but
at the end of the day i know where i'm
not wanting i can't be over there
because everybody ain't gonna feel like
me or him you know so but that was big
for the culture i felt like because even
though i think i don't know street [ __ ]
and we ain't changing [ __ ] lives and
you know charity moving but it just
shows you like the growth
like we can all grow we can all speak
and talk to each other we can [ __ ]
around you know what i'm saying like
times times change bro we got kids we
got a family let's travel let's talk
let's joke let's have fun it's like all
the killing and [ __ ] like i just
it's nothing like you i don't i don't
agree with that [ __ ] no more man gang
banging is stupid you feel me like that
[ __ ] is outdated that [ __ ] is out of
here i mean isn't that really kind of
like the um
the root of the issue is that blood has
been spilled so yeah so when does it
stop because it's like it's it's a
non-stop cycle of like
one and like responding to bloodshed
with more bloodshed and i would always
ask my homies too and i'm like how does
that [ __ ] gonna stop
like if he killed him he killed him it's
just going to keep going down the line
so how do it stop and they was like well
[ __ ] that's why you got to holler at the
kids because the older folks are already
stuck in this same this this frame of
mind so you try to go talk to the youth
and hopefully the youth will have a
different frame of mind
and then i'm like yeah i'm like that's
cool you can go speak to them but they
still got to go home
you know what i'm saying you still got
to go home where they where they're from
where they from you know the mama the
daddy the auntie in the house they still
talking to crazy [ __ ] like and then
you'll just learn growing up you feel me
it's just learned mentality man that
[ __ ] is crazy so i don't really know
how to [ __ ] that [ __ ] again
i mean i mean unless we just got a crazy
financial freedom and i don't yeah i
mean i remember like when nip passed and
um there was a like kind of like that
march that big you had uh organized i
know that was like a really big deal but
in terms of like
i don't know where do you feel because i
feel like in part man some of this
younger generation is more wider than
the older generation these younger
generations is on another level
and then on top of that they really
don't get
they really not outside like we were
like it's it's more so on the internet
there's some internet [ __ ]
but they are crazy because when they see
each other these things got big-ass ars
they shooting up [ __ ] shooting some call
of duty ass [ __ ] yeah they shooting up
parades and all type of [ __ ] like going
on like
so bruh it's crazy but man i don't know
man that [ __ ] is wild man the younger
generation compared to us is just really
wild but what big you did do a special
man for the for the culture for sure
like but not and i i even asked him i'm
like big you why the [ __ ] you just can't
go
get every [ __ ] from every set and say
you know what we ain't doing this no
more and if you [ __ ] is doing this
then we depend everybody or are you
gonna keep doing this matter of fact you
[ __ ] can't beat from the set no more
[ __ ] no more gaming over you go over
there so why the [ __ ] y'all just can't
do that nigga's like [ __ ] it ain't that
easy
if it was that easy it's not that easy
but right it's you can do it you think
so it's doable if you brought [ __ ] to
the march i bet you there's a gang of
older og [ __ ] that feel the same way
like man i ain't trying to do this [ __ ]
no more and i ain't trying to see you
get killed you get killed you get killed
but i'm from this [ __ ] so majority
counts you feel me like majority rules
[ __ ] it we just gonna keep saying [ __ ]
it yo we gotta stop the interview real
quick tell us about uh i'm gonna tell
you about our partners in my bookie man
make sure you go to mybookie.ag right
now
it's gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well you can bet on everything
in my bookie man so look what you got to
do is go to mybookie.com right now
just go to my bookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you
a deposit match free money up to a
thousand dollars so if you sign up and
you put 200 bucks in they're gonna give
you another 200 to bet with
thousand they're gonna give you another
thousand to bet with let's go for the
suns all the way just throw all your
money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [ __ ]
round because yokish is going to [ __ ]
pound them in their ass probably great
odds on that one anyway
my bookie.g my bookie just [ __ ]
google the [ __ ] my bookie use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
deposit free money free money up to a
thousand dollars let's get back to the
interview with trail yo um
just on some business business [ __ ] man
at child's peak like the clothing line
was doing big numbers like you said it
was in tilly's
it was definitely a cultural thing
um what was the best year you guys had
[ __ ] i think we made like 15 million off
the close off the close that's huge it's
like 15 million off the clothes and i i
i i mean you know i started some [ __ ]
with my girl you know i've told a story
before but you know t-rong gave me some
money he like man he go he'll go 15 000.
he like man try to start last kings and
try to do it up
basically this is this is it
because i really ain't got no money i
can't pay you you don't know how to do
[ __ ] yo go run this [ __ ] manager manager
all the [ __ ] you i did it before but he
like i gotta you know keep elevated so
here goes some money [ __ ] hurry up and
gotta do some [ __ ] i'm like all right
let me go try you feel me i took that 15
i ain't gonna lie i gave fire to my girl
and i'm like [ __ ]
you my plan b so you know i got ten now
yeah yeah you gon you make it happen
with the girls [ __ ] and i'm gonna make
it happen over here with this little
last king [ __ ] feel me like you made it
happen and i made it happen 15k to 15
million man i turned 10k yep 10 10
million man and shout out to my homeboy
low cause my homeboy low introduced me
to ryan and then when ryan i got
introduced to ryan ryan felt like okay
this is this [ __ ] is attached to a
celebrity i can sell this [ __ ] to
tilly's he had the relationship once
tilly's bit
it was over i was living right down the
street north hollywood on fair
you feel me like in the gallery i was
living right there me and her and she
was shipping off the floor she was
shipping off the floor i was shipping
off the floor i had my little homie andy
he was shipping hats you know i'm saying
he was a designer at the time
i didn't have [ __ ] you feel me then when
i met that [ __ ] and then we went to
tilly's i got that check my first little
check it was crazy the tilly check gotta
be wild i gotta check nowadays it's like
if you get into zoomies
oh yeah i know when cookies got into
zoomies they changed their whole
business like it's over it's like a wrap
five thousand stores what and i'm
selling this [ __ ] and y'all want
accessories
backpacks hats socks everything not just
only t-shirts like they want everything
the shirts also the hats because i feel
like the hats were more popular
well the hats were way more popular than
anything yeah that happened
way more popular than anything yep
i don't miss the era and i'm not talking
about just y'all where it was like
animal print pockets on a black tee you
remember that yeah they see this [ __ ]
like here's a cheetah pocket on a black
t-shirt yeah
and
here's a cheetah brim
on a red hat on everything that [ __ ] was
crazy i will say this though
i'll give it to the cool kids i think
the cool kids originally brought the
snapback [ __ ] back but tyga made a
commercial like the retro starter hats
i give that to tiger all day like taking
it to like mainstream well i'll give
that [ __ ] to tas arnold pass arnold made
that [ __ ] go he had a brand called
t-cell yeah yeah which tiger would would
rock he was rocking the team piece of
hats he was rocking the teaser hat and
we were rocking ice cream and [ __ ] like
that and then you know one day i will go
like we need to do our own [ __ ]
you know and then we i we kind of
figured out i got with this young [ __ ]
named glenn
you feel me um who ended up suing me too
the partner right
what i'm saying i got with this young
[ __ ] [ __ ] glenn yeah
[ __ ] might shoot me again i ain't
seeing that that's just crazy he won the
lawsuit no you don't understand kev he
won yeah he was
but it's all good i'm saying if he
didn't win i wouldn't be right here
that's crazy there it is damn i'm glad
your ass won [ __ ] but yeah man you know
[ __ ] sue me or whatever the case may be
but it's it's all good man but [ __ ] we
got out that [ __ ] i forgot the [ __ ] i
was for the sake i don't remember either
what was i just saying i don't know this
[ __ ] going crazy yeah it's going crazy
uh what's like obviously with the at the
end of the day going so well your [ __ ]
going so well are you doing anything
outside of the content space
uh no i have a family channel i've been
having a family channel before i want to
know on youtube but yeah on youtube
having a family channel named heather
and terrell my kids me and her we be
doing it up on there but uh
as far as doing it up by myself i'll
probably do something with my girl you
know um a podcast doing something with
her
and then i'm gonna just stay at no
jumper you know what i'm saying i'm a
builder build there before i take my
[ __ ] left you feel me i ain't
i know everybody like bruh you got the
potential you're doing it ah leave get
out of there and i'm like damn you know
what i'm saying i mean it it's not even
been a year right
it ain't it's gonna be a year on april
6th so yeah
two more days it's gonna be a year but
yeah i'm like damn i'm a loyal [ __ ] you
feel me and
and i i don't i ain't gonna let the you
know i ain't gonna let the cloud get to
me like so you know i still got [ __ ] to
do and i should have got time to build
and then i'll venture off is there any
any situation where you can see yourself
getting back into the music business
uh
[ __ ] no
[ __ ] these [ __ ] in music i'm not doing
none of that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is crazy i
don't i just don't like the fakeness i
don't like being lied to and it's just
the music industry is just a bunch of
[ __ ] lying to each other all
day i i ain't got time for it you feel
me like you say you gonna do this don't
do it like you say you're gonna be here
don't be here you say you're gonna give
me this money don't give me the money
like [ __ ] [ __ ] like and then
at that time i was taking a lot of [ __ ]
personal you know because of where i'm
from we just built on like loyalty and
just be a man of your word like
[ __ ] wasn't doing that i was
burning a lot of bridges
if you was telling me one thing and you
and then you didn't do it [ __ ] i was on
your ass [ __ ] you feel me like
i would i used to be i should go hard i
used to go home i ain't gonna lie dog i
should go that's just probably went too
hard just
shout out to this guy man banging hoover
hanging out with the kardashians at a
certain point
they don't even know who the [ __ ] at
their family events
[ __ ]
they're like hold up everybody had to
research and thinking like hold on this
thing you have over here
but i was a caller
this was hey
did you meet kylie like how much surgery
had happened already was it was it like
it was like at the beginning of like
kind of like the lips and i don't know
about no surgery she had man she i just
know she was always a cool young girl
man did you always see the billionaire
in her um yup i always seen the money
and [ __ ] and the taste in her whole
family man her whole family just a real
family-oriented [ __ ] man and i
and being around them is cool they
taught us a lot of [ __ ]
and they taught me a lot of [ __ ] how to
move how to have your household uh well
coordinated like these [ __ ] is
moving scenic man i just love everything
that they do on everything what's it
like um
being around kanye because you know
kanye executive bruce a gold album
well yeah being around kanye
i only been around kind of this is crazy
i only been around kanye like at the
family like birthday parties and [ __ ]
like that so it's like only like a small
talk hey what's up
and um
i don't know t-rod just never really
brought me around uh kanye maybe he felt
you know i was embarrassing some are too
crazy like i was like
but he'd bring you to the children's
birthday party yeah but that makes sense
but that's after not not at the studio
with kanye but come over and hang out
with the 15 year olds yeah i mean that
[ __ ] crazy but [ __ ] it yeah what i'm
saying listen man uh it's dope to see
what you're doing um go follow the show
it's on i mean you guys drop every
wednesday right every wednesday six
o'clock your family live don't worry
about nothing
how many interviews now are you doing in
a week or is it just
wherever i get it
where whatever wherever i get in where i
fit in you know i'm saying because he'd
be doing interviews two three four a day
for sure so if it ain't no time slot
it's over for me but whatever time i got
open i got somebody to feel it and i'm
doing it and i drop every saturday so
you drop every saturday every saturday
even though i know that's not a cool
conventional time for you to interview
every saturday i drop an interview every
saturday and then you and your wife how
often do you do the family thing we try
to do it like three times a week even
though we'd be bullshitting though but
still check us out man heather and
terrell is it hard
because like i'm on [ __ ] no jumper
and i'm married as [ __ ] and i'm like i
couldn't be over here as much like
you know i'm over there the other day
and the chick who blew all the phoenix
suns is there i'm a sons fan so i
naturally want to talk to this [ __ ]
i'm like yo so you suck devin booker off
tyler euliss let's go through the names
i want to know but like i'm like [ __ ] i
couldn't be over here often because
there's so much there's just a lot of
well i'm used to it man we got a women's
clothing brand i'm saying sorella
boutique man y'all go check that out so
really
but i'm also just you know i'm used to
it my girl always having girls around we
got a women clothing store we're just
coming out the dressing room naked
she doing photo shoots girls coming out
half naked and this is bad some of them
should be going on in that studio though
they wipe the couches down that's all
i'm saying they wild doing that [ __ ] i
heard some camera guy got butt fingered
or something on the on the patriots [ __ ]
he's crazy i seen that [ __ ] homie they
were there and it was like hey oh no
josh just showed me on the computer and
he was like watch this and i'm like
watch what they was like don't watch it
bruh and i'm like what and i'm like bruh
why would you do that bro and they kept
the couch and they kept the couch i'm
like did y'all sanitize it is he still
uh filming for the
is the camera guy still there they got
fingered on the couch but no no no he
held no i don't know i feel like that
[ __ ] worked for patreon or whatever
i feel like if if you if you do that
like you almost sign your resignation
letter if you like it's great because
you work there while we was there [ __ ]
no he wouldn't last you could have been
quit you're probably crazy yeah what
every day every wednesday he probably
want to shoot himself in the [ __ ]
head there it is man tira i appreciate
you bro